selon la drees la quasi totalité de la
population française est exposée à un
risque de détérioration de sa santé par
manque d'activité physique ou
sédentarité l' agence sanitaire appelle
donc les pouvoirs peuvent et cas à
s'emparer en urgence de ce dossier
quelles sont les conséquences et comment
lutter on vous en parle avec vous julia
seger bonjour julia alors il faut
d'abord distinguer l'inactivité physique
et la sédentarité c'est quoi la
différence alors effectivement la
sédentarité ça correspond à tous les
temps que vous allez passer dans la
journée allongés ou assis hors du temps
de sommeil donc ça va correspondre au
temps que vous passez sur votre lieu de
travail par exemple de vendre votre
ordinateur à l'école dans les transports
motorisés ou alors encore lors de temps
de loisirs notamment devant les écrans
il faut dire que la sédentarité s'est
petit à petit invité dans nos vies
surtout dans les personnes qui vivent
dans les pays développés de l'hémisphère
nord avec notamment des pays justement
où il y a un secteur tertiaire très
important on va en parler tout à l'heure
et c'est effectivement très différent de
l'inactivité physique ou là ça fait tout
simplement référence au fait que vous ne
faites pas d'activité physique ou alors
trop peu pour pouvoir atteindre les
recommandations de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé qui recommande je
rappelle 30 minutes d'activité physique
minimum 5 jours sur 7 alors vous l'avez
dit dans votre introduction
selon la dernière étude de l'année 16
95% des français aujourd'hui de 18 à 64
ans serait en manque d'activité physique
ce qui pourrait les mener à une
détérioration de leur santé mais quand
vous regardez les chiffres en détail
vous vous rendez compte qu'en fait ce
chiffre est assez gonflé alors vous
inquiétez pas on n'est pas tous en train
de devenir des zombies quand vous
regardez ils se sont en fait ils ont
établi déjà ce sont des données qui ont
été récoltés en 2017 et ensuite ils ont
établi trois différents seuils avait un
seuil de capacité cardiorespiratoire
avec justement cette recommandation de
30 minutes de sport par jour 5 jours sur
7 ensuite il y avait un seuil de travail
musculaire environ 40 minutes par
semaine et ensuite un seuil
d'assouplissement de 40 minutes aussi
par semaine et ils ont compté dans ses
95 % toutes les personnes qui ne
respectaient pas les trois critères je
sais pas si vous faites 40 minutes
d'assouplissement par semaine
mais on comprend mieux pourquoi 95 % des
français sont aujourd'hui
dans cette étude en tout cas
on prend bien aussi que le but c'était
d'alerté on a compris le message c'est
vrai que c'est un réel problème parce
que vous avez aussi beaucoup de
personnes qui vont cumuler
l'inactivité physique et la sédentarité
si par exemple vous allez au travail en
marchant mais qu'ensuite vous passé sept
heures devant votre ordinateur vous êtes
considérés comme actifs mais sédentaires
c'est complexe mais on commence à
comprendre l'idée qui est plus
intéressant c'est le fait que cette
inactivité physique touche inégalement
la population on dit que 70% des femmes
n'atteignent aucun des seuils c'est ça
l'étude révèle des disparités au sein
même de la population les femmes dont
70% d'entre elles n'atteignent aucun des
seuils ou en tout cas sont en deçà de
tous les seuils pour pouvoir justement
avoir une bonne santé contre 42% des
hommes alors ça s'explique notamment
dans un premier temps à cause d'une
inégalité des offres des sports au plus
jeune âge mais aussi à cause de la
maternité on constate que quand les
femmes deviennent moment et bien si
elles ont du temps libre elle ont
tendance à le consacrer à leurs enfants
plutôt que d'aller faire du sport alors
que les hommes voilà peut-être que c'est
un petit peu plus une priorité
l'inactivité physique ça touche aussi
beaucoup plus les personnes qui vivent
en ville notamment à paris que dans les
zones rurales alors on voit aussi que il
y as pourquoi est ce que c'est un
problème justement cette inactivité
physique et bien il ya de nombreux
problèmes par rapport à la santé on en a
parlé avec alicia fillon allait chargé
de mission à l'observatoire de
l'activité physique et de la sédentarité
est aussi docteur en physiologie de
l'exercice en écoute
clairement on peut dire que la
sédentarité en tout cas et est vraiment
a vraiment un impact hyper important sur
la santé de la population on a des
chiffres qui peuvent aider aussi à se
rendre compte de ça par exemple simple
fait de rester assis trois heures par
jour est responsable non augmentation de
près de 4% des décès toutes causes
confondues mais vraiment et le risque de
mortalité augmente de façon extrêmement
marqué à partir de 7 heures par jour de
temps assis avec une augmentation de 85%
des risques supplémentaires de mortalité
cardiovasculaire pour cette heure ou
plus ça c'est devant un écran jours or
on est beaucoup passé sept heures ou
plus devant un écran notamment toutes
les personnes qui travaillent dans le
secteur tertiaire
des recommandations quand même pardon
julien oui alors les recommandations
vous les connaissez les 10000 par
c'était une recommandation de l'om est
sauveteurs français sur deux est
aujourd'hui n'a pas connaissance de cet
objectif santé et 4 76% d'entre nous ne
ne parvient pas à ce chiffre le but
c'est réduire évidemment le temps
d'écran essayez de vous déplacer
évidemment en marche en partant partout
vous allez mais surtout le but c'est
vraiment de réduire ces temps de
sédentarité si vous travaillez devant un
ordinateur essayé toutes les 1h 1h30 de
vaud levée de passer des coups de
téléphone par exemple en marche